from the ringers uh his show uh slow
news day is fun
and so much uh to talk about where the
man who covers the nfl he's a boxing guy
too right
we're boxing a little bit of boxing the
match went down this week i enjoyed his
piece on that from the ringer kevin
clark how are you sir
i'm i'm great thanks for having me you
got it what's on your mind
literally like right now what's on your
mind
i mean there's so much what is it i was
expecting
i was expecting the match to give us
some tea leaves we could read
on the aaron rodgers situation me too
and then it turned out rich that aaron
rodgers was just like everybody else he
doesn't want to talk about work while
golfing
right like that's an american tradition
he doesn't like his job
he just wants to play 18 and he doesn't
want to talk about work and so i
i think we saw pretty quickly there that
uh that he's not going to give us any
clues in what the next three weeks are
going to look like before camp starts
wouldn't have been great if he's
standing over that game that that that
uh match ceiling putt
he's ready to put uh phil and brady away
three and two and he just says you know
what i got something to say
and he just goes on some sort of tony
soprano
uh you know um uh dr melfi type rant
on brian gudekunst and just laid it all
out for the entire country to hear like
this is what it's been all about
and now i'm gonna make this putt and he
jars and he walks off that would have
been even better
but we weren't going to get that in a
million years kevin that would have been
the best
i i think that that aaron rodgers is
maybe you know almost probably all the
elite quarterbacks who played in this
league for a long time rich
he aaron might be the most media savvy
and most thought out guy i put peyton up
there but they're obviously extremely
different personalities
um he understands exactly kind of what
needs to be said in every situation
and so the fact that he didn't do that
says to me
i don't know maybe he doesn't think he
can he can force his way out in the next
three weeks maybe he doesn't
get to denver or any of these these
places um so yeah i think from a content
standpoint
i'd allowed for him to look straight
into the camera like jim halpert in the
office and say here's where i want to go
um but i i just i i just feel like the
lack of options
made it so he just kind of he just kind
of didn't do anything
right except go out and play the best
golf uh
that he possibly can and actually carry
deshambo a couple of holes
you know like he really did he was
terrific and i
that was my one takeaway from it you
know um
kevin because i watched every minute of
that not only because i thought it was
so well done so well produced i enjoyed
it i loved watching the
the golf course and just seeing the
beautiful vista of montana i loved all
of it it was
visually pleasing it was entertaining uh
but i was hanging on every moment just
for even a hot mic
thing you know just even something to
get something out of it
and what i do literally take out of it
is rogers looks terrific
he's mentally focused he just seems to
be chill he's got it all lined up
he might not know exactly what he's
going to do he perhaps
already does know what he's going to do
but what what's definitely needs
we need to see him out on the field
because it would be a horrible shame and
a waste
to not see him play football being as
physically and mentally locked in as he
appears to be
right now i totally agree and the fact
you know the fact that he's spent the
last couple of months
in places like hawaii at the kentucky
derby he's engaged he seems like i mean
maybe maybe uh the last couple of months
where he was just resting and not going
to mini camps and ots might be the best
thing for his football now it comes down
to whether or not
he's going to show up on july 27th when
when the entire league is supposed to
report
um but i actually think that when we saw
him the other night he looked pretty
pretty chill he looked pretty locked in
he looked pretty confident and so maybe
there's a case you made they should just
spend every off season in hawaii maybe
we shall maybe we should all spend the
offseason in hawaii
everybody in the nfl the nfl media let's
all go from february to july in hawaii
locked in man i'm in on that um you know
the day before the training day
uh training camp reporting date uh kevin
is the uh the the
shit's uh shareholders stock meeting in
green bay and we've been joking that he
should show up like jimmy chitwood
amongst all the townspeople and say it's
time for me you know play ball but
you know i'll i'll only play if guru
queens goes uh i don't think that will
happen but
uh the trade's not happening it's just
not it's there's no way
a trade is happening because the the
draft picks that they get from somebody
now
will only be made worse for the packers
by how successful rogers is going to be
so it's just not going to happen until
next year if at all
you know i totally agree with you i mean
if he goes to denver right now
they're a top four afc team and then all
of a sudden what you get the 27th pick
in the draft is that going to get to the
next aaron rodgers even though that that
was almost where rogers was picked
uh you know when he came in i promise
you there's no such thing
as as equal value for trading an elite
quarterback does not exist ever
and so you're going to take a loss and
you better have a really good reason
whether that's jordan love is ready to
play
or or whatever so i could see it being
next season but i really don't see
the packers um standing down and and
trading him
there's just no way they could they
could get any sort of value for him that
is anywhere close to it and so i just
and also you know
when when the initial story came out
rich remember the story was only two
teams called
about aaron on draft week and the nfl we
see is a little different from the nba
where i think nfl teams are so set in
their ways and so ready for 2021 that
even if aaron became available
it's not like 25 teams are going to put
their bids in it's not like
you know when james harden becomes
available in the nba i think that
should be kind of a limited market for
him in 2021 um even though he is the
reigning mvp and the best player
football just because of how teams
operate they all there's so many teams
even with with above average
quarterbacks think they're set for 2021
because they're a little more
traditional and not going to kind of
swing for the fences
kevin clark from the ringer here on the
rich eisen show and sean mcvay and uh
and uh and the uh
podcast that peter schrager does with
him uh for the ringer
that was a fascinating conversation with
kyle shanahan especially since
it sounded like shanahan was all pissed
off that mcvay
beat him to the punch on stafford you
know that that
that that he he was grinding tape to to
move on from jimmy garoppolo
um when when mcveigh surprised him
saying guess what we've already grinded
tape on
uh on on a replacement for golf and it's
stafford see you later
i i love that hole that was a nice raw
rare
uh behind the curtain exchange right it
was really good and it's
you need a guy like mcveigh to and and
for shanahan to talk so fortunately
about that and
i was i was surprised at how
open shanahan was and he was in cabo and
said he said
it ruined his vacation he thought he was
gonna have more time um to get stafford
he was out with his wife uh
having dinner and then he got the call
so i thought it was a really interesting
look behind the curtain about just how
badly they wanted stafford and i think
that everybody who knows football
understands how good matthew stafford is
i spent some time with stafford
two years ago for a story and he's one
of these guys
who i i remember dan arlovsky who played
with him tell me about stafford
uh he said that he's one of the few
people who who really says i don't care
what people think
and really means it like everybody says
oh i don't care what people think
stafford just wants to be a good
teammate he plays through injury all the
time he plays through bad offensive
lines
all of these things stafford is in the
nfl community is so widely respected
and so i think that the the biggest
endorsement of a matt stafford in 2021
is the fact that two of the smartest
coaches in the nfl sean mcvay
and kyle shanahan were desperate to get
him to the point that shanahan
is still salty he didn't get him well
and it made me also think that all trey
lance has to do is fog up a mirror and
make it seem like he's not gonna go
you know totally um you know
uh in the wrong direction and that the
job's his
right i mean because they're they they
were ready to
they were ready to just move on from
garoppolo right then
and there if they could have pulled off
the trade for stafford certainly
you know uh they gave up all those draft
choices for lance
uh they would have given him up for
stafford one would think
right 100 you know i the best phrasing i
saw
about the shanahan lance thing is that
it's not a scheme
fit it's a scheme expansion and and what
i guess the the
what's gonna happen here is that kyle
shanahan's gonna be able to run his base
offense and do so many more things than
he's ever been able to do
uh with jim mcgregor even though
grappler is a nice athlete and all that
stuff
right lance is gonna be able to do three
times more they're gonna be able to
expand the playbook and i think that a
coach like kyle shanahan
um is going to really enjoy what he's
going to be able to do i mean these guys
at heart whether sean mcvay kyle
shanahan sean payton bill belichick
they're football dorks
and they want to be able to do as many
different things as possible
and treylands gives you dimensions with
jimmy garoppolo doesn't so i agree with
you i think it's going to be lance early
in the season
i get i would guess it's not week one uh
but it's gonna be pretty quickly because
if you're kyle shanahan
aren't you spending june and july just
coming up with plays for trey lance i
mean you're definitely not coming up
with plays for jimmy garoppolo you've
been there done that you tried to move
on from them
already so i think there's going to be a
plan in place to get freelance in there
early
how quickly does justin fields get out
there kevin what do you think about that
one
so i've looked at the schedule before
they played the packers in mid-october
and i think you don't want him to make
his his debut in
in against green bay that's just too
much pressure especially if roger's
there or especially if jordan love is
there you don't want to
the two young quarterbacks going off
against each other i think in week three
they play the lions i think that might
be good unless dalton sets the world on
fire
i i really don't think uh he's going to
make it to
to october i think they want to see
justin fields i think justin fields is
nfl ready
i think matt maggie has his flaws
certainly but he can make quarterbacks
better and young quarterbacks
particularly we've seen that in the past
um so i'm i'm in favor of a september
switch
i think it just gives them a little bit
of coverage to roll andy dalton out
out there the first couple weeks and it
seems like uh you know now that he's
signed his his rookie deal as well
um it looks like trevor lawrence might
be ready to be named the starter of the
jacksonville jaguars right
kevin i mean it's just like he hasn't
been ready he hasn't been ready they're
not ready they're
you know the the hoops that they are
jumping through
to to to make it seem like there's a
process and then there's a scheme and
then that there's an earning of a of a
job
when we all know the coach who's trying
to create that atmosphere took the job
because trevor lawrence is being drafted
is really just some of the greatest
um you know contortionism we've seen in
the nfl in a long time i'm enjoying it
immensely it's entertaining i'll say the
same thing about lawrence i did about
borough the year before which is that
trevor lawrence won this job
probably last november okay like the the
competition ended last november at
thanksgiving
of 2020. i mean this is they didn't go
out and sign a big name
um they're they're obviously you know
the
at one point i remember right before the
draft they asked urban if he was gonna
draft trevor lawrence he said well
that's the direction we're heading and
it's like okay man like we can
you have the first overall pick you
don't have any other options to start
them
like i promised you trevor lawrence was
coming in as the starter um
you know well before whenever they named
him the starter and in a couple of weeks
or even a month kevin i'll do you one
kevin i'll do you one better i'll do one
better he trevor lawrence won this job
on i just looked it up while you were
talking december 28 2019 that's when he
went on a 67-yard touchdown run against
ohio state
that was the moment that he won the job
we just didn't know which team he was
going to win the job with
we knew it you know we just didn't know
that at the time
exactly i mean there's some players
where you shouldn't even pretend
and i think now the whole red shirting a
rookie quarterback thing
it's it's a lost art it's never going to
happen again
these guys are coaches are under too
much pressure um and also
by the way quarterbacks are coming in
more nfl already than ever have been i
mean it's like the whole ten thousand
hour theory
of the seven on seven leagues these guys
are are throwing so much remember andy
reid a couple of years ago
you should say you know the problem with
with college quarterbacks and things
coaches used to complain about
was that these guys weren't throwing in
college they were you know in the number
of the 80s and 90s it was kind of rare
to see a pro-style offense
nowadays these guys will throw i mean
300 times in a you know a couple weeks
if they play in the big 12.
um so i think that there's just it's a
different type of quarterback
and they're more ready to start in
september october of their
of their rookie year than maybe a
quarterback 10 15 years ago kevin clark
here from the ringer a few minutes left
with him here on the rich eisen show
what story are we not talking about
which story do you think is
is lingering out there it's bubbling
beneath the surface going to be a big
story but we're we're all stuck in
what's aaron rodgers thinking land what
do we know what are we missing right now
kevin do you think i i i know this is
going to sound
completely insane and i'm going to i'm
going to regret saying it uh because
it's never actually happened
well now you have to say it i actually
do think we're sleeping on the dallas
cowboys
um and i again i i that that is
something where we've never slept on the
dallas cowboys ever it's never happened
we
we've overrated the dallas cowboys but i
think when you saw the offense last year
um and what they could remember that
prescott and then you see that they
hired dan quinn and i i listen i don't i
don't think dan quinn is going to come
out here and be
you know 1985 buddy ryan here but i
think there's going to be a confidence
there
and they went out and they they
basically rearranged their entire draft
in order to go defense only
uh retooled that defense and and i just
really think in a division it could be
weak i really do think the cowboys um
could be a a real i don't think they're
nfc contender exactly
um but i i really do think that they're
on kind of the the next level the nfc
teams where they're going to be making
some noise december and october and i
kind of think
because of the disastrous year last year
because the dak prescott injury for some
reason
for the first time maybe ever and maybe
this will change with hard knocks
uh we might not be talking enough about
the dallas cowboys
are you kidding me might not be
talking enough about the dallas cowboys
but you don't think
i mean that would make them nfc
contenders though kevin i mean you're uh
i'm trying to square what you're saying
because i mean i i actually i agree with
you i mean
listen there's not i think that we're
gonna see a changing of the guard the
saints are not going to be
contenders like they have in the past
okay obviously the niners and the rams
will be contenders
uh obviously the packers with aaron
rodgers would be contenders but it's not
so deep and i think when you look at the
afc rich
you have a real problem which is there's
a lot of afc teams who are really good
but i don't think they're as good as the
chiefs and i really don't think i think
the bills are on that second level
i think the ravens are on that second
level and i think there's other teams
that have a chance to be in a second
level
the nfc i think is anybody's confidence
so i actually
i i do think that there's a case you
made that the cowboys if
they are as good as they think they are
could be one of these final four teams
um and playing the nfc champions game
and then it could be anybody's game i
really do think the nfc is just not as
deep as the as jfc and doesn't have the
chiefs so it's a different game
all right i'm going to see those two
takes and i'm gonna raise you with two
crazy takes
okay or not may not be so crazy uh why
why can't a um an nfc
championship run be made out of the nfc
east
by the washington football team and ryan
fitzpatrick why can't that happen
how about that one well why not i think
the deck press guy so first of all first
of all i i agree
in with parts of the football team take
i think their front seven is
nasty that's terrific it's terrific
but if you're staking a take if you're
coming up with the take let's pretend
this is poker
do you really want ryan fitzpatrick to
be your quarterback for three or four
huge games yeah because i'll suck out on
the river about
10 times on the night you know
and then all i got to do is suck out on
the river five straight hands in a row
and i'd think crazier things can happen
and i win i win the entire pot i win the
part of the night
like that's you know it's funny because
the the the football team and the
cowboys have opposite problems
which is that we know the football
team's front seven of defense is going
to be good they just need a certain
level from their offense
and the cowboys have the exact same uh
issue which is they have one side of the
ball
which is really good the offensive they
just need mediocrity or
or b minus performance and b minus
performance from the cowboys defense
would get them into the
nfc champions game hunt and so i think
that if you combine those teams they win
the super bowl but that's not how this
works
um they're both incomplete teams that
need a boost from the other side of the
ball
and i think that i'd rather have um
you know i think the biggest the biggest
question once you get to january's
quarterback and i'd rather have dak
prescott
than ryan fitzpatrick but i i i see your
take yes i understand it i'd
rather have the cowboys all right and
then on your afc uh my response to your
afc stance
is you mentioned the ravens as a um i
guess second tier if you were second
behind the chiefs team and i i
understand why you'd name them
out of that division but what about the
team that actually gave the chiefs the
toughest time in the afc playoffs last
year
are you are you buying on the cleveland
browns why can't they
i have their season i am okay i am and i
think the browns are right in that
conversation
um and and i i love that team i think
that
the biggest endorsement i'd say rich of
the 2020 browns and andrew berry and
kevin stefanski is
you know the the browns made the
playoffs last year they won a playoff
game
and people weren't considering it the
greatest miracle of all time like kevin
stefanski
has made uh success in cleveland
look like it should always be happening
and i think that that's such a huge
thing when you just think about the
history of the cleveland browns
how impressed i've been that it seemed
very natural when it was happening last
year anyway it wasn't a cinderella story
at all
uh i do think of that group let's say
those four quarterbacks
um of the of the top asp teams have
already named baker is probably the
the quarterback i bet on the lease but i
still really like baker mayfield
um the roster is just awesome they went
out and they fixed their their secondary
um to they'll get grant delphi back they
went out and got some of the best value
signings the best slot corner
um on the free agent market there's
going to be some real roster talent
there
i just don't think i i think the problem
with with the afc
is that the chiefs understand their
flaws and they fix them brett beach
had a saw the glaring weakness in the
offensive line obviously last january
and he went out and built one of the
best offensive lines basically on the
fly
and i just don't know how you're going
to beat the chiefs this year with that
patrick holmes is already going to spot
you a handful
of points and so i agree that the browns
are in this mix
i think they suffer from the same
problem as those other two teams which
is they're just not as good as the
chiefs
barring an injury or a crazy collapse um
the best they can hope for
in my book is afc championship losers i
would be remiss if i did not ask you
before you leave what's going on with
fury and wilder what's going on oh gosh
um so if you're not a boxing fan
uh you should know that so this fight
has been delayed for over a year now it
was contract contractually obligated to
happen after the second one
even though tyson fury had signed the
deal he's going to try to be able to
fight uh anthony joshua
afterwards so wilder and fury were going
to fight on july 24th
uh yesterday it came out that fury uh
and his camp have tested positive for
coven
so the fight has been pushed back to
early october
uh between fury and wilder so now the
fury joshua fight with the fight most
people in the boxing world were looking
we're looking forward to
has to get pushed back even more um i
guess the the
the overarching theory of being a boxing
fan
is to expect disappointment and uh so no
boxing fan is surprised to be
disappointed today
because uh this is why we can't have
nice things well uh kevin i i understand
that i was once a guy who
was covering a henry akhenwande fight
that got pushed because he got hepatitis
um and then we were all wondering if
hepatitis is another way of couldn't
sell out the top of uh madison square
garden so
uh we were all wondering that back in
the day that's how long i go back with
that whole business but
hey man um thank you for the time this
has been fun let's chop it up again
um and and uh do this in short order
thank you
any time big fan richard no right back
at you and if you ever want me to
complete a home and home on any of your
pods plural i'm more than happy to do it
just let me know i'd love to hear that
we'd love that dance let me use that
you got it you got it that's uh kevin
clark i follow him
by kevin clark you should too right here
on the rich eisen show a lot of
food for thought there hey you watched
all the way to the end thanks for that
watch more right here